sieh dir doch einfach was anderes zu
arbeiten influenza und durch starke
braucht das ist zu geil das ist eine
doku leute mancher da freute dieses
video sieht wird sich denken was jan
meintest du nicht dass du keine hilft
mir videos mehr hochladen
worauf ich dann nur entgegnen kann ja
dass das heißt tatsächlich gesagt dass
ich wollte eigentlich weniger bis gar
keine hilfe mehr machen aber sebastian
wieso lebst du denn jetzt schon wieder
in hilfe video hoch dass meine lieben
kinder liegt in der tatsache begründet
dass ich heute einfach keine bessere
idee gefunden aber damit herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ganz so schlimm wie es gerade ihn
dargestellt habe ist es tatsächlich
nicht denn ich habe wirklich ein video
gesehen was mich persönlich interessiert
es ist das handy-video famous süchtig
nach likes hat wird er hilft mir seite
gefunden dann hab ich was ich auch mache
geguckt ob andere youtuber schondorfer
gittern
lukas schon darauf reagiert insofern
würde ich das video nicht wählen aber
aber leute dieses video liegt mir am
herzen weil das thema likes anerkennung
in sozialen medien und die allgemeine
influenza welt ja für mich auch als in
von uns eine sache ist die mir oft
begegnet und die ich in dieser relativ
großem umfang richtig beschissen findet
warum wenn wir gleich sehen leute wir
schauen in das video rein wie verhilft
mir seine normalerweise an die sendung
fangen doch immer an mit so einem grenzt
dummen grenzdebilen moment wo man sich
denken das ist so hängen geblieben da
bin ich erst mal eine runde um den block
um sich abzukühlen zu beruhigen aber
problem deutschlands in franzosen halt
wirklich so also ich kann jetzt nicht
die parodie erkennen so wo ist die
parodie
ja man hört förmlich heftig für euch
reise ich natürlich um die weltliga sind
überhaupt so lange hashtags endlich
erlaubt von instagram oder zumindest
meiner meinung nach sollte nicht
verboten seien leute aber es ist
wirklich zu sweet es ist so saftig genau
so ist das in wirklichkeit das ist keine
verarsche und keine übertreibung leute
im juni christ passt das bestes beispiel
falls ja dass ich kein check des ab wie
viele leute flexen mit fake luxusuhren
fei rolex fei jpg fake patek philippe
auf instagram und wollen damit da schon
dass die kratzer sind als sie eigentlich
sind leute diese ganze welt ist wirklich
so fällt wird es hier dargestellt wird
warum ist das so ein geiler eine geile
unfreiwillige parodie
es ist nicht eine parodie oder eine
verarsche oder lustig weil es so drüber
ist dann das ist so nah dran leute ich
versteh ich muss auch noch in eure lage
reinversetzen ihr bekommt ja auch
oftmals halt nur das was viele leute
euch auf instagram zeigen ihr seht die
leute oftmals nicht im echten leben
treffen nicht im echten leben deswegen
hat mir nicht so die erfahrung gemacht
die ich gemacht habe
jetzt wo ich schon eine weile hinter
szene unterwegs mit ich sage ich denke
er wird vom glauben abfallen würde vom
glauben abfallen
ihr seht irgendwelche in fahrzeugen oder
was auch immer auf instagram und denkt
schöne frau so die wirkt cool so
attraktiv und hat sich den echten denke
also was ich sagen will es ich weiß
nicht wer das da draußen hören muss ich
hätte es auf jeden fall hören müssen
bevor dieser szene war der täter ist so
viel show dabei also genau deswegen habe
ich dieses video auch ausgewählt es ist
mir einfach so ein herzensthema wenn ihr
die erfahrung gemacht hätte die die ich
gehabt habe werde genauso dabei es ist
zu krank wie fake diese ganze welt ist
von instagram stars nicht allen aber
vielen oder einigen sagen was man so bei
youtube youtube sind halt wirklich real
so muss man da ist man also die jetzt
noch politik weil ich selbst als ich
angefangen habe aber wenn man mal so die
branche youtuber mit der branche
innsbruck war vergleicht findig sind
youtuber schon eine million mal wieder
zumindest aus meiner eigenen erfahrung
mag sein dass auch blinde weil ich halt
überall so ja der gesang ist das ist
eigentlich eine doku hier wirklich
lustig
freundin schwester etwas über das ist
will seraphina wie das junge mädchen
jahr heißt einfach so helfen wir so
tipps geben und so auf den rechten weg
im leben leiten und sich beantwortet
einfach ein hashtag hash der
gesamtsieger seraphina du du du kannst
du uns weitermachen
du gehst an der realität vorbei du wirst
keine instanz ihrer vier stück mehr
hashtag wie viele leute auch schon auf
die fans unterwegs sind heutzutage es
ist wirklich zu kranker ich sag's euch
leute im internet gibt es keine regeln
da gibt es keine regeln die leute machen
gefühlt alles um erfolgreich zu werden
es ist wirklich einfach crazy decker da
fällt mir nur fällt mir noch herr staeck
samt ein muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
wünschte ich wünschte ich könnte euch
die ganzen storys erzählen die ich kenne
die ich kenne leute wirklich ich will
mich nicht pushen das jetzt irgendwie
gut so es gibt leute die 1000 mal mehr
service kann als ich meine zum beispiel
nike ist wirklich der absolute bord was
das angeht aber ich allein ich bin nicht
so krass turbo verletzt und ich kenne so
viele storys von leuten die sachen
gemacht haben um irgendwo irgendwo zu
landen in einer schau oder was weiß ich
was oder auch bekannte große youtuber
auch muss ich auch zugeben die so ein
klinisch sauberes image um die hinter
den kulissen sachen mache dick war
wirklich schlimm aber okay
[Musik]
ist zu geil das ist eine doku leute ich
sage euch hier an ort und stelle ich
nehme dieses video auf in köln am 15
20.21 um 16 17 das hier ist eine
dokumentation über influenza in
deutschland und leute die in fonds
erwerben wollen hätte niemanden der sich
das als sein ziel ausgegeben hat alles
so alles gut leute immer leute dabei
unterstützen wenn sie ihre ziele
verfolgen
aber das ist wirklich eine dokumentation
genauso ticken die leute genauso keiner
will meinen normalen job machen will
einfach keiner mehr
ich hoffe einfach voll aber egal gut in
der stelle muss ich sagen dass ich jetzt
auch gerade keinen normalen job machen
aber ich hätte an sich kein problem
damit ich habe einen uni-abschluss ich
habe praxiserfahrungen so kein problem
ich kann auch normalen job machen wenn
das jetzt nach hinten losgeht es tut mir
so in der seele weh leute ich hoffe ich
hoffe ihr fühlt das genauso wie ich dass
das hier eine dokumentation ist sie
wurde auf dem falschen kanal hochgeladen
hilf mir ist der falsche kanal das hier
muss auf arte oder zumindest spiegel tv
das ist eine dokumentation genauso das
ist keine übertreibung genauso ticken
sie so viele jungs und mädels in
deutschland ich schwöre aus
ich schwöre es euch séraphine ist 18 und
ständig online ihr perfekt perfekt
perfekt die hat alles die bringt alles
mit
die bringt den unbändigen wunsch mit
sich zum höchsten lebensziel zu erheben
einfach nur follower zu haben weil leute
dann sehen wir mal ganz ehrlich was
zählen die anderen sachen im leben was
zählt es erfüllung in seiner arbeit zu
finden eine sinnvolle arbeit zu machen
was zählt ist sich mental anzustrengen
bei seinem job mental was zu leisten zu
sagen hey ich hab mein kopf heute
benutzt und nicht nur ein bild gepostet
was zählt es noch eine privatsphäre zu
haben leute und alle von euch die sich
jetzt diese fragen zu hause beantwortet
haben wissen die richtige antwort nichts
leute es man ganz ehrlich es ist alles
egal hauptsache ich bin berühmt der rest
egal wirklich der rest ist einfach
komplett egal großer traum
in fluren werden und millionen follower
haben das auch einfach ein land um der
nation eine volkswirtschaft man den
begriff benutzen darf halt einfach auch
in jedem verschiedenen beruf leute
braucht keine ahnung und land braucht
handwerker sonst haben wir ein problem
man kann funktioniert nichts mehr ein
land braucht leute die heizung
reparieren können land auch leute die
leute pflegen kann den krankenhäusern
gerade jetzt gerade land brauche ärztin
land auch leute die tür gefahren wo soll
es hingehen wenn alle deutschland in
vorjahren waren
das ist schon ein cooler job aber es ist
dagegen nicht alle eure probleme
wechseln
ich habe ja selbst von so den weg
gegangen so also keine ahnung verstehen
wir 30 jahren alle sind influenza mit
einer million follower oder 100000 oder
was auch immer
und keiner fährt mal die züge oder wie
soll das funktionieren
zur bürger jackie jackie wir jackie
cooper bei mir vorbei und dann erkläre
ich die noch mal wie das funktioniert
mit dem korrekten um dann mit deinen
verloren diese leute sind der grund
dafür dass du jetzt mit soll es
zumindest im echten leben den krassen
marken klamotten rum laufen kannst und
ich so darstellen kannst als wärst du
die nächste angelina jolie was du nicht
bist du niemals werden wird aber okay
das stimmt aber auch leute das stimmt
auch es ist wirklich krass glaube ich
wie viele leute auf instagram operiert
sind männer und frauen ich glaube es
geht bei frauen ist allgemeinen gänge
rasten also keine ahnung brüssel gemacht
ja sowieso ist auch jedem selbst
überlassen oder so ich weiß was ich
schon davon so aber viele leute sind
halt nicht so wie sie geboren sind so
und kann man einfach so objektiv sagen
glaubt andere leute sehen dass dann
wiederum und denken sich sogar die sich
ja viel krasser aus als ich so dann
folglich der jetzt mal die hat der
sachen die ich nicht habe ich finde dass
ihm die kraft und dann habe ich die
jetzt zum star weil die besser aussieht
als ich weiß nicht
sie sehen einfach so perfekt ist ganz
toll dass so viele ja da ist typisch ist
das ist wirklich das verursacht bei mir
stress dieses video verursacht bei mir
stress auf dieselbe art und weise wie
keine ahnung aber auch korrekt nach
einer ecke ganz positiv auf die ähnliche
art und weise wie wenn ihr so eine weile
so einen wecker sound hatten also einen
wecker sound dann habt ihr gewann 9
und dann spielt irgendwann diesen song
der wecker sound war absolut nach
monaten und euer herz ist sofort zu
genauso ist das dk es ist wirklich zu
krank was den deutschen abtreten des
sees zu kranken aber es gibt auch viele
positive beispiele muss man sagen von
wirklichen ehrenmänner unter den fans
sein die einfach wirklich gerade typen
sind korrekte typen von justin ist so
eins reviers zu eins die jungs von
gewitter im kopf die sind auch wirklich
solche ehrenmänner ganz wirklich ehrlich
also es gibt auch einige
positivbeispiele übrigens wenn ich jetzt
einen nicht gerade dabei ist es nicht
dass er kein positivbeispiel es aber es
gibt eben auch viele krasse sachen ich
muss mich auch entschuldigen leute ich
habe mich so in rage gelabert ich sehe
wir haben jetzt schon 22-mal aufgaben
das ist schon wieder viel zu viel
material wir sind aber bei minute 330
ich hoffe es war für euch interessant
was ich heute so ein bisschen so
hintergrundinformationen erzählt habe
schreibt mir mal die kommentare
soll ich davon in zweiten teil machen
keine ahnung wollte mehr zu wissen wie
auch immer hat findet hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen video oben könnte meinen
abonnieren ich möchte schon raus macht
gut